marvel's avengers features plenty of
familiar faces from the comics and fun
nods to the wider marvel universe
however there are more than a few
aspects of the title that may slip past
even the biggest bands of earth's
mightiest heroes
much like the other avengers thor
retreats from the public eye after a day
however unlike iron man and the hulk
thor odenson
seemingly didn't devote his time to
moping over his failures
instead it appears thor took a human
alias to continue helping normal human
beings
when he appears again after a day thor
is wearing a shirt that indicates he has
been volunteering at a nearby hospital
he even has a sticker on the shirt
identifying him as d
blake fans of the comics may recognize
this as a reference to donald blake
the name of thor's original human host
while hunting for the backup drive that
contains
jarvis kamala khan finds an old photo of
the avengers and their civilian
identities
while the majority of the group is
recognizable as the lineup featured in
the video game
there's one extra member in the photo
situated on the ground in front of the
rest of the team
is a man wearing a baseball cap and a
t-shirt with a bull's eye on it
fans may recognize this mysterious man
as clint barton
aka hawkeye the team's archer hawkeye
stars in his own dlc missions for
marvel's avengers
as does his protege kate bishop it's
worth noting that neither of the
hawkeyes are directly mentioned in the
events of the campaign
instead it appears as though the only
reference to hawkeye is this
blink and you'll miss it tease when
black widow finally rejoins the rest of
the team
on the chimera there are a few objects
in her private room that players can
interact with
one of these is a small red music box
with a ballerina figurine inside
not only does this music box clear up
how widow ended up choosing the code
name
tiny dancer but it also acts as a
reference to her dark backstory
in the marvel cinematic universe and
some versions of her comic book origins
natasha was trained from a young age to
be an assassin
the place where she received this
training was called the red room
during her time there natasha was
implanted with false memories of being a
ballet
dancer at a prestigious school since
joining the avengers as black widow
she has struggled to leave that part of
her life behind it seems the game's
version of natasha
may have finally come to terms with her
violent past
while aim is the predominant threat to
the world in marvel's avengers
it appears another corrupt organization
from the comics may be lurking in the
shadows
during kamala's first big brawl with
ames robots
eagle-eyed players can spot posters and
a banner in the background
for roxanne comic book fans may
recognize this
as an advertisement for the roxon energy
corporation
a company that has run a foul of just
about every hero in the marvel universe
the marvel cinematic universe has also
heavily referenced or
featured roxanne in fact a roxon oil
tanker served as the stage for the final
battle sequence in iron man 3.
prior to the a day opening ceremony
kamala runs
into some bullies who question her love
for the avengers
they insinuate she's not a real fan and
tell her to get out of here
to that kamala responds when the mob and
the press
and the whole world tell you to move you
plant yourself like a tree beside the
river of truth
and you say no you move these words were
originally spoken by captain america in
amazing spider-man number 537
these were captain rogers words of
wisdom for spider-man when he was at his
lowest point
the marvel cinematic universe spun this
speech in a new direction
giving it a more sentimental value in
the movie captain america civil war
a version of this quote was attributed
to the late peggy carter
even if the whole world is telling you
to move
it is your duty to plant yourself like a
tree
look them in the eye and say no when
kamala and the hulk break into ames
inhuman testing facility
you can spot a sign behind kamala that
reads subject to
naja while this label might seem random
it actually points to the existence of
another character from the comics
nausea was the name of an inhuman who
gained her powers from an event similar
to ade
after the release of the terrigen mists
naja developed several new abilities
including invisibility and flight she
also found that her body changed
shape taking on a more reptilian
appearance in the comics
naja teamed up with several other
inhumans including dante
a version of dante notably appears in
marvel's avengers
where he is depicted as a member of the
inhuman resistance
if nausea exists in this universe then
perhaps the two of them will join forces
in a future story
the opening mission of marvel's avengers
sees the team facing off against
taskmaster and his gang of mercenaries
at one point the incredible hulk catches
a bus before it can go tumbling into the
water below
the bus is only on the screen for a few
moments but if you look closely
you can spot a license plate bearing a
rather historic number
the license plate on the vehicle reads
av10963
which could reference the fact that the
very first issue of the avengers was
released in 1963
however it could also allude to issue 10
of the avengers
which came out that same year the cover
of that issue dramatically declared the
avengers would break up in that month's
story
in the marvel's avengers mission that is
exactly what came to pass
which makes this the more likely
reference check out one of our newest
videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite games are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]